Speaker 2: Let's keep going. I mean,
the calls have really been quite good
today. We don't want to depart
from that, if you can imagine,
that would be sad. Let's go to Mark
from Los Angeles, California. Mark,
what's going on? Keep us going here.
Speaker 1: Hey, David. Hi, Jeremy. Yes. Oh, good
question. First of all, I just want to know, do
you think that Mike Lindell has that? I remember
you described a sort of persistent delusion that
is focused on California. Yeah, because it was
just watching that interview. First of all, it was
exhausting. Congratulations to be able to survive
that, because, I mean, after some point of his,
he's so relentless. You just want to start yelling
at it. I know, because he just can't. He doesn't.
One of the things that is terrible about talking
to him is that he doesn't really listen to you
and try to process what you're saying. Right. And
and try to come back with a cogent answer
that actually pertains to what you said.
He just has this gif gallop of of of things
to say. And once you try to once you knock
something down. He denies that, but not fully.
Speaker 2: And then moves on to something else.
Speaker 1: More things. Yeah. And it's just
like I was just like, you need help or.
Or maybe someone needs to interview him
who literally is just as rude as he is.
Speaker 2: Right. No, it's difficult. And I got
both positive and negative feedback about how
I handled the interview. And the thing is, you
have to kind of think about other ways to handle
it. I could interrupt a lot more, but I already
got some criticism for interrupting too much. I
could not interrupt at all, in which case we would
have one guest gallop for 30 minutes and then we
don't go absolutely anywhere else. You know, you
can always make the argument that I could have
been more prepared and you can always be more
prepared. But the problem is he can always find
some small fire to set with something I haven't
heard of, no matter how much prep I do. So it
is really difficult to handle those interviews.
Speaker 1: Yeah. It's kind of reminiscent of what
Bill Maher was saying. Why he was it Bill Maher?
Speaker 2: Sam Harris. Sam Harris.
Speaker 1: Same here. Oh, you know. Exactly.
Yep. Wow. Like, it's, like, telekinetic. But,
yeah, that's exactly what I'm saying. What?
What Sam Harris is saying why he won't have on
anti-vaxxers. Right? Because he just, you know.
Speaker 2: They can always say we're going.
Speaker 1: To anybody.
Speaker 2: From Kathmandu's
regional hospital. You know, it's like,
I don't know. I didn't see that. Does it.
Speaker 1: Change that? Oh, that's a win, right?
Speaker 2: Right. Absolutely.
Speaker 1: Yeah. Yeah, yeah. Are you are.
Speaker 2: You originally from,
like New York or Long Island?
Speaker 1: I am originally from Washington, D.C..
Speaker 2: Oh, interesting. Oh, I thought I heard
a little a little bit of a New York accent there.
Speaker 1: No, no, no, no. Washington, D.C.,
Born and raised. Born. And how in Mercy Hospital
went to Howard University. Beautiful. Yeah.
And then the other thing I wanted to say is
I was watching one of your live feeds
and you were playing some voice mail,
and there was a there was a black
gentleman who was was discussing how
Herschel Walker fills in certain very negative
stereotypes about black people. And you want to
play it too long because it got a little dark.
Speaker 2: I was worried about like terms
and conditions, having an issue on like
some of the platforms we were on. Like,
I know the point he was making, but it could
be the type of thing that we got dinged for.
Speaker 1: Okay, I see. I see. Because I was
thinking like I was actually watching MSNBC
and the one of the shows on there with hosted by
I forget her name. It's a black woman but but she
one of the her guests actually made a really great
comment about the fact that Herschel Walker is an
insult to black excellence and that he fulfills
many of the stereotypes that white people have
about about black men. He literally is a walking
embodiments of almost every single concept, right,
that black men have been scrapped with since
slavery. You know, so and that's one of it's
funny enough. Are you familiar with Rashad Rashid?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. He actually tried
to interview what's the guy's name. He was. He
was caught having sex with men, which is. Okay.
I have no idea. I don't know. I'm. I'm the guy
that. You've interviewed him twice. Oh, Jesse.
Speaker 2: Peterson.
Speaker 1: Jesse Lee Peterson.
He didn't make it through to two questions
with Justin Lee Peterson. And he's just.
Speaker 2: Going to have to check that out.
Speaker 1: Because he could smell it a mile away.
And if you're familiar with Aaron Aaron McGruder
show The Boondocks. He very much embodies that
that character, that stereotype that
he has on there, that sort of like,
you know, it gives a a visceral reaction to
African-Americans that's kind of shocking.
And we immediately want to just shut it down
immediately because it kind of calls back to
some things that are very dark. Well, Michael.
Speaker 2: Listen, you really said it all. I
appreciate the call. I hope all is well in L.A..
Speaker 1: Yeah, absolutely. Absolutely. And and,
of course, I love your show. Keep that commentary.
And yeah, I hope to. Did you make did you say
anything about the debate that happened in Ohio?
Speaker 2: Yes, we streamed it live,
Mark. I got to run because I got so many people
waiting. All right, my friend. I think there's
Mark from L.A. with many, many questions, some
of which some of which I was able to answer.